facility
thank you for the invitation to to speak
at this Workshop
so unfortunately it seems like I brought
the wrong set of slides I understand now
that this is a proof complexity workshop
and here I am talking about
combinatorial optimization
so let me very very quickly try to make
some connections
so just as
uh proof complexity
common reporting optimization is a rich
and beautiful area of mathematics and
computer science
even maybe slightly more than proof
complex they call that sort of
optimization has had an impact outside
of math and computer science
probably the reason that most of you are
here is that your airline airline
company which
which you were traveling around some
kind of combinatorial solver to figure
out the plane schedule
uh if this talk gets boring so that you
check your laptops or cell phones and
you know those someone has been running
a commemorial solver verifying the
hardware
another interesting uh application of
combinatorial solving this for
motivational purposes if
and it's at some later point in time it
turns out that you need the kidney
transplant and actually a sort of
combinatorial optimization solver will
try to figure out how to match
recipients and donors to maximize the
number of people who survive and get
kidneys
so there are lots and lots of
applications of combinatorial solving
and optimization as we all know these
problems are typically very hard there
and be complete sometimes and be hard
and so sort of as a as a proof
complexity theorist this means that I
already know that this is exponentially
hard there's no hope unfortunately the
practitioners didn't pay any attention
to this they insist on solving these
problems and pretty much in your time
using a lot of of of different
combinatorial optimization paradigms
such as spoonial satisfiability solving
constraint programming next linear
programming
um interior linear programming
satisfiability modular theories so so
there are amazing algorithms that solve
many many challenging
um coronatorial solving and optimization
problems out there in the real world and
with like millions of variables
with the one big caveat that how do we
know that they give the correct result
so in fact we know that they don't it's
fairly well established in the
literature that even the very best most
mature commercial solvers sometimes get
the answer wrong
and we don't know when
um
obviously if you if you if they output
the solution you should be able to check
feasibility although solvers sometimes
even get that wrong so they output
solutions that you can see are not
solutions to your constraints but how do
you check if if a SAT solver runs for a
few hours and says that your formula is
unsatisfiable how do you actually know
that that is true or if your
combinatorial solver that was
Distributing kidneys between donors and
recipients says that this is the optimal
solution that we actually really want to
know
that the solution is optimal how do we
know that this is true like your airline
company if the solution wasn't optimal
then you're just losing a little bit of
money but here we're losing lives and
non-optimal solutions are like just
completely unacceptable
and yet we're in a setting where even
the best combinatorial solvers Doom get
their answers wrong from time to time
so what do we do on this well one thing
you obviously you do you do extensive
software testing to try to weed out the
bugs the only problem is this doesn't
work
like empirically that hasn't worked
there's another mathematical approach
that is very principled very attractive
you write down exactly how your solver
is supposed to work you give a
mathematical specification and then you
use like an interactive theorem proverb
or something to to prove of what you
have implemented adheres to this formal
specification and now you have a
mathematical proof that your software is
correct and there are tools that can do
this like all the way down to machine
code
the one problem here is that modern
combinatorial solvers are far too
complicated for these techniques to work
they just don't scale no chance
okay so formal verification would be
very nice but it just doesn't work in
practice
so
what seems to the most promising
approach or what I'm arguing is the most
promising approach is to make solvers
certifying or to make them use
pre-flogging which means that we're
asking them now to give not only an
answer to the problem but they should
also provide a proof
a proof that this answer is correct
what this means is the this uh software
algorithm should not just when we run it
we get an answer but we also get a
machine verifiable proof and we should
be able to feed the input the answer and
the proof to a proof checker
and then
we check what the proof Checker says and
if it says that everything is okay that
we can trust that the solution is okay
or the answer is okay and otherwise we
know that there's enough
and now you see that this this proof
check here this is just a standard
standard proof verify so now we're
actually getting close to proof
complexity but from a slightly
different direction than what is usually
the case
so what do we want uh from proofs
used in practice
well we so one thing that since it's
important to understand the scenario one
thing what's not going to happen is that
we design a proof system and then we
start to rebuild solvers from scratch
for like constraint programming or
satisfiability module theories or
something they're like Decades of very
very sophisticated coding has gone into
this
and will have no chance to replicate
this work so we'd like we have to take
the solvers as is
and that means that the proof system
that we have will have to be very
efficient very concise if this is going
to fly it should be easy to basically
take an existing state-of-the-art
algorithm and then just add uh
concise explanations of what the solver
is doing and our proof system should be
strong enough to express the kind of
sophisticated reasoning that the modern
solvers do
there'd have to be a strong concise very
expressive proof system on the other
hand the whole point
why we're doing this is that we want
proofs to be dead easy I mean the the
whole point with this workflow is that
the solver is a very very complicated
piece of software that we don't
understand but this checking process the
proof should be so simple that checking
the proof is more or less a triviality
okay a good undergrad student principal
be able to code up the proof checker so
that you know once we know that the
proof checks out we're really confident
about everything
and that means in particular that
whatever proof system we design it
shouldn't be like a one-time Hack That
is tied very specifically to this
particular
solver so that I have to know how the
solver works okay it works I somehow
have to trust that it's correctly
implemented it should be an abstract
proof system
for which I can check the proofs without
necessarily knowing what the solver is
doing
okay
so
and this is to highlight that there's
like a clear conflict here uh between on
the one hand the proof system I want it
to be very very expressive and on the
other hand because because I want to
support efficient proof logging like the
process when the server generates the
proof but on the other hand
in order to be make verification
trustworthy I want the proof to be to be
very simple so it's sort of there you
can ask like are we making any progress
it seems like we're having a very we
have two completely opposite demands on
our proof system
so are we you know will this work well
there's one thing that's in our favor
that potentially we could get this to
work because now we're not trying to
prove the whole complicated solver
correct we are somehow just trying to
abstract the way a concrete proof and
verify that proof and maybe that's a
simple task
and in fact we if if we get this to work
then at the end of the day we want to
use formal verification but not for the
solver but for the proof check because
the proof Checker should be simple
enough
that you can actually make the proof
Checker formally verified so you have no
idea what the solver is doing but if the
proof turns out to be okay then you're
fairly confident that the proof Checker
is formally verified and so now we can
trust the result was there a question
over there is it like the Primal Global
message so they give you this
like if you have a primal solution and a
dual matching I mean if I was doing for
instance linear programming I'm sure but
I mean if we're doing like zero one
integral in your programming in the
short answer is no yeah but you're
absolutely right that something like
that would be great but you know we
don't have it right
but now the point is that
here is you know a point where where
proof complex they can contribute
because suddenly everything that is
causing trouble for us in our daily
lives is now suddenly an advantage we're
struggling to prove lower balls because
we study like you know proof systems
like say polynomial calculus or cutting
place or Bound in the trigger it's hard
to prove your overbounds because these
proof systems are like can do unexpected
smart things
but now we can turn all of this in our
favor now we want the proof system to be
strong we want them to be able to have
short ways of certifying complex
reasoning so if we have struggled to
prove lower bounds against the proof
system and understood that it can do
lots of strong things then now we could
use this in our favor
to design a method to certify
correctness of combinatorial solaries
and just to say
we can do this this is much more about
much more than just certifying the
correctness of the output of a
certifying solver
it gives you something that formal
verification cannot give you suppose for
instance that you have a formally
verified piece of software and it runs
on a super Computing cluster and you
have a hardware failure which you will
have on a large scale computation which
is okay
and now even if your software is
formally correct I mean once a node goes
down you have no idea what will happen
but if you have
proof generation
then the proof will be wrong so you I
mean if you don't get a correct proof
then you see that there's something
wrong in the computation and if you do
get a correct proof then you know that
the fact that this node went down did
apparently not affect the end result
one thing that has been the case in all
pretty much all papers so far actually
implementing proofloading in state of
the old solvers is that even in
extremely well tested software you
discover new bugs
and the way you discover this is you
have a bunch of test cases they all pass
so you get the right result and then you
switch on proof logging and you see that
the solver is taking shortcuts in order
to reach the correct answer because you
can see that for instance some case
analysis and the proofs the solver
claims that okay I've done an exhaustive
analysis of all cases now I'm
backtracking and the proof Checker says
wait a minute isn't this this weird
Corner case that it's true it will never
ever happen but I don't see that you've
considered it
and such errors will be all over the
proof even though like the output is
always correct because it's very weird
especially case never triggers
um
now you can also potentially use the
proofs generated by
combinatorial solvers to understand that
the much
sort of finer level of granularity than
before what the solver is actually doing
how is it reasoning and if you analyze
the proof you can for instance trim the
proofs and see which part of the proofs
you really use well that can give you
information about which kind of
reasoning seems to be more or less
important and maybe also give you ideas
for how to improve the reasoning in your
solver maybe for new heuristics on top
so this is like the pros you can mine
them for information that will maybe
drive improvements in algorithm
development
and almost by definition once you have
run your solver on a problem and you
have not only the answer but also proof
log then at any given time in the future
you can check that the solution to this
problem is indeed what it is claimed to
be and you don't even need the original
solver because you have the proof and
you can run a proof ticket
which in the end you could also Envision
like a future where you use this kind of
thing also a proof will tend to explain
it will tend to certify not only that
an answer is optimal for instance but
why an answer is of them
so you can Envision that you will
combine this with when you solve a
problem to optimality the proof will not
only certify that this solution is
optimal but it will tell you like
because of these constraints and because
they combine in a certain way you cannot
get a better solution and there are like
a number of applications for instance in
artificial intelligence where what
people are asking for today is I don't
just want the answer I want to know why
the answer was what it was and it's they
seems to be something that truthfully
so this is trying to pitch that this is
like an interesting technology
uh if we could do it and that it's
basically all of this is a proof
complexity question but from a
constructive viewpoint
so does this exist well it turns out yes
it does exist in the in the Boolean
satisfiability Community there are lots
of different proof program formats in
the sap competition I think going back
till 2013 or 2014 uh proof vlogging is
actually compulsory in the main front if
you want to take part and win the main
track of the competition you have to
give machine verifiable proofs if you
claim that the formula is unsatisfied
uh but
this success story has stayed with such
we don't have anything similar for say
constraint programming or for sat based
optimization or or mixed engineer in
your programming and in fact even for
sat a problem these days is that if you
want to use the most Advanced Techniques
like if you want to use if you're
solving a cryptographic instance you
want to be able to do parity reasoning
or if you have a highly symmetric
instance that you want to do symmetry
breaking then it's not known in the in
these proof formats how to do proofs
that certify the correctness of breaking
symmetry for instance so we have a
somewhat paradoxical situation today in
the sub competition where you have to
switch off techniques that we know given
exponential Improvement in reasoning
power and you have to switch them off
because you can't generate deficient
Goods
this is not entirely satisfactory so
question yeah so two questions so first
of all in practice when sub servers are
used uh is actually you
I think it depends
um the point is it should be impressible
so true flowing should have extremely
small overhead so it should not be an
extra cost to run your solver with proof
um whether they actually do it that you
know Intel or something I don't know I'd
have to ask but in principle like if you
have basically I think also if you run
your soul with proof vlogging like for
thousands and thousands of instances and
the proofs always work out then at some
point you sort of get confidence
yeah I mean the storage requirements are
the or the probably the issue in some of
the long groups right
yeah yeah I mean for for Applied
problems I think proofs tend to be not
too large I mean proof vlogging has also
been used in I'm not mentioning this in
the site the proof of examples we use to
solve for instance problems in extremely
combinatorics and these are typically
very very hard problems where what the
SAT solvers do is a sophisticated form
of brute force and then you get gigantic
groups
it doesn't happen that actually checking
the proof takes longer than the solver
brand
checking will typically take longer uh
yeah so like um you know within a factor
five or ten longer and the reason for
this is
um sort of the way this is going to work
and this is yeah so this is a good point
and it is different from when we in a
TCS setting where we talk about proofs
we usually think about maybe
probabilistically checkable proofs where
you check them like uh with in
logarithmic time or something but then
you sort of in that setting you know
what the answer is and you can use a lot
of nifty mathematics to build a very
very sophisticated proofs here you
should think of the solver doesn't even
know what the answer is
but it has to build the proof in an
online fashion on the fly so anything it
does it's going to write down okay now I
did this now I did that I still have no
idea whether I'm satisfied or
unsatisfied but let me tell you what I'm
doing and then after one hour you
suddenly decide oh it sounds satisfiable
okay then and there the notes you wrote
down should be a value proof you don't
have time to go back and sort of patch
it up and and do something nice
uh so typically
[Music]
checking the proof will actually be take
longer than generating the proof but it
should be like a small problem
some 25 years ago there was a lot of
excitement about the area of group
sharing code yeah that's uh John's
Network like a developed used to be a
profession here how conceptually what's
the relationship with any
I guess that would be closer to formal
verification I think that like the
general problem with these techniques is
that they're extremely attractive but
they don't scale I think like real world
applications so yeah people look there
if any possibilities I'm not an expert
on proof caring though I know that for
former verification and if you talk to
the expert informal notification you
actually work on this they just say that
you know people have been trying to to
like make certified versions of babysat
solvers
sophisticated very very interesting work
in terms of performance
thank you
my question was uh uh when you first
album when you output the first fruit
you said that it takes longer to verify
it than maybe generate but
uh after you do the first verification
of the proof I my understanding is that
sometimes you get like you clean up the
proof as well and so maybe you could
clean up the perfect treatment but
you're absolutely right that like I can
work on the proof I could see what part
of the proof do I actually need to
verify the second time uh yeah yeah sure
it varies but but typically you can
train improves a lot so if if you would
you know store the proof for posterity
then you would probably try to trim it
significantly
so where are we okay so that's the
current equation
like Pro vlogging would be wonderful it
would have all of these amazing
applications uh we know in satsoling
that it partially works but not Beyond
sat solving and not even for advanced
that sort of things okay so why are we
here today so what I'm going to tell you
about is that if you take basically what
the SATs online people have been doing
uh but you generalize it to zero one
into the linear inequalities instead of
Clauses and instead of the resolution
based proof you switch to coming planes
and you extend it in a clever way with
suitable rules
then you can do not only all of sat
solving but it seems you actually get a
general purpose proof system that so far
has been able to do anything in
combinatorial optimization that we are
this is what I want to tell you about
um so I'll start by quickly reviewing a
little bit about sat solving and making
the connection between cdcl and
resolution which I think many of us know
but I'll try to do it quickly and and
tell you about the extension rules that
are used for set proof logging
and then I'll tell you about more
advanced stat techniques and how sort of
cutting planes comes into the picture uh
and hopefully tell you a little bit I'll
be able to tell you a bit a little bit
about more Advanced Techniques such as
constraint programming
um symmetry breaking I hope I definitely
want to Define also since it's a proof
complexity Workshop I want to define the
formal proof system in the cookware
sense that comes out on this and that
gives rise to some interesting questions
like how strong is this proof system
actually do we need all of the strength
of this proof system
so just to make sure we're on the same
page so we're we're starting with the
sub problem so we CNF formula conduction
of of closets every Clause is a
disjunction of literals that is
variables or negated variables bar is
negation as that's always asked to
decide whether a formula like this
is satisfiable or not
so how what do we do well there's the
DPL method from the
six days which is basically just an
intelligent form of backtracking and
then what uh has driven the revolution
inside solving is conflict driven close
learning where when you want to
backtrack not only do your backtrack but
you compute a new Clause that is implied
by your formula you add it and it will
cut off parts of the search base going
forward
and you also use uh the conflict
analysis to guide a lot of other
heuristics we don't care about this for
proof vlogging purposes all we need to
do is to justify backtracking and to
justify when we're adding new Clauses
why it's actually valid to add these new
process so this is a general thing like
for proof vlogging how the SAT solver or
another solver figures something out
what heuristics it used it sort of
pre-flogging is oblivious to that we
just need to certify the correctness of
the conclusions found we don't care so
much how these conclusions
Okay so quite quickly if we have a
formula like this what would the sub
solver do well it would start by
assigning some variable maybe setting P
to false
and then a lot of the time a Saturn does
unit propagation so it looks at Clauses
here for instance if p is set to false
then you see that the first Clause says
that well U also has to be false or else
I've immediately violated the Clause so
that's called Unit propagation and the
third solver will write down that it
propagates you because of the reason
plus P or not U
and you always propagate until
saturation now there are no further
propagations allow the start solver
maybe decides to set Q to false and then
this second Clause propagates that R has
to be true the third Clause propagates
that W has to be true again there are no
further propagations so now maybe we
decide on x
uh being false
and now since and and the Saturn is
keeping like a trail of which is an
ordered list of the assignments made so
far now U is false X is false so this
close propagates that y has to be true
so I write down down with uh not with U
or X or Y as the region clause
and then this Clause X or not y or Z
propagates that Z has to be true but now
we have a conflict because we're
violating not y or not so
back in the 60s we would just say oh
apparently X was a bad decision let me
flip it now a modern sub solver would
instead say let me analyze I made three
decisions and then I made some
propagations I have three decision
levels I'll go over what happened at the
last decision level and try to figure
out what went wrong
and here for proof complexity series
what will happen is just we'll do a very
simple resolution proof we'll do a
trivial resolution proof
so we start by the conflict clause and
the last reason Clause they disagree on
them so just by removing said and not
said and taking the union the rest of
the literals you realize that any
satisfying assignment to these two
Clauses has to satisfies it has to
satisfy X or not y
and then we can look at the next reason
clause and this Clause that we have
derived
and they disagree on Y and it follows by
the same type of analysis that any
satisfying assignment to these two
Clauses will also have to satisfy U or X
and now I'm doing this very quickly but
at this point the SAT solver will say
aha I only have one variable left from
the last decision level now this is a
good place to stop I'll add this Clause
to my formula and I'll backtrack
okay
in fact it will back jump it will say it
will look at what's how much can I trim
the trail while still having this Clause
propagating and it turns out that
for this conflict this
decision on Q and all the propagation
for completely material so I'll trim
them away but I'll keep the decision on
P and the propagation on you
and observe that given those two
assignments this new Clause propagates X
to true and now I'm back again I'll do
exactly the same cycle of propagations
and decisions except in this case I
don't need to make any further decision
I get a propagation on node X or Z and
then I immediately get a new conflict
the conflict analysis here is very
simple I just resolve these two clauses
I get not X I've learned now that in any
satisfying assignment X has to be false
and this is true regardless of anything
else so now the solver trims the whole
trade starts over from the top and says
I know X is false well then this Clause
implies that U has to be true
well then this Clause implies that P has
to be true
but that's a conflict with this process
and now note that I haven't made any
assumptions no decisions so now I know
that the format is in fact unsatisfiable
one way of seeing this typically here
the solvers would actually terminate I
could run one final Conflict analysis
and I'll see that I actually derived the
empty clause
okay
so if we want to do and from this
description you can already see like how
would I do proof vlogging
well just look at what the conflict
analysis is doing it's using the
resolution proof system that from C or X
and D or not X I can derive C or D
and
so
basically the main Loop in Conflict term
and close learning is just generating
resolution proof so this this is
ignoring Korean in processing we'll get
there in a minute
but sort of morally most of what a set
solver does is actually captured by the
resolution rule so if I wanted to do
proof vlogging for the main Loop of a
cdcl solver I can just take this
execution take the conflict analysis and
string them together and write down this
resolution proof and this would be my
profile
I mean this is this is not quite the way
it's done I don't for reasons of time I
I won't go into the details but in
principle
like a sad solver could do a proof Row
game by breaking down
which is clearly efficiently verifiable
and you see the proof will like scale
with the running time and it will be
again you can see also verification time
will will scale
uh with the execution time but the
scaling will be like
so that's
I mean close learning now satsolders
will do more than this sometimes they
will say oh uh I want to keep track of
the value of the conjunction of X and Y
I want to introduce a fresh variable
that actually takes the value of this
conjunction
now the way you could do this is I can
just if you think about it I could add
these three Clauses to my formula
is this okay yes if a is fresh this
should be okay because you know given an
assignment to X and Y A will just
propagate to whatever value it should
take
um so we want if we
should be able to do proof logging for
sat solvers then we need a rule that
supports something like this and it's
clear that the resolution can't just do
it for fundamental reasons I mean these
resolution can only derive implied
Clauses and these Clauses are not
implied
but of course we know that the extended
resolution proof system can do this
so it turns out that I don't want to use
extended resolution I want to use a
slightly nicer rule there are a number
of different rules in the in the
literature for this
for deriving so-called redundant Clauses
so what's a redundant Clause a clause is
redundant if adding it doesn't change
the formula from satisfiable to
unsatisfiable that's like what at least
what sad people mean when they say
redundant you can discuss whether this
is good terminology or not this is
like establish term in the literature
and all of these different rules are
captured by
something that we call redundance based
strengthening building on previous work
by by bus and toppen
so all of these different rat rules and
propagation redundancy rules are
basically special cases of the following
Rule and here comes like the first
interesting proof complexity rule so I
claim that we should be able to add a
clause C to a formula f
if and only if I can find a substitution
Omega which I will think of as a witness
so with substitution it's mapping
variables either to truth values or to
other literals for which the following
implication holds
so F and not C
should imply F and C under this
substitution Omega
if this holds and I will need some kind
of efficiently verifiable way of
checking this implication if this holds
then you should allow me to add C that's
what I'm saying
okay and if you see this for the first
time it might not be obvious why so let
me try to very quickly sketch like the
interesting Direction so which also
tells us how we should think about Omega
so what we're worried about
is that we have an assignment Alpha that
satisfies f
itted when I add C that is sort of the
bad case
okay but if that is the case then Alpha
satisfies F and not C
so in that case
by the fact that we have this verifiable
implication Alpha satisfies F and C
restricted by Omega
and now just by unpacking this
definition this means that Alpha
composed with Omega satisfies both f and
c
I'm just sort of doing this very quickly
but I'm just unpacking the definition of
what a what a restriction means what is
your how's your composition
I'm applying Alpha I'm applying Omega
first
and then once I've applied Omega I apply
Alpha
so sort of you should think of omega as
a local patch so if Alpha is not quite a
good assignment because it violates the
C then by applying Omega first and then
Alpha I get a patched truth value
assignment that is guaranteed to take
care of both what I had before and the
new plots
and this is is essentially sort of
in in some moral way this is sort of
what extended resolution is also but
this is a I think this is a nicer way of
thinking about it and it's also
generalizes the so-called rat rule which
I won't even explain what it is but what
is what is being used in in
um
just to very quickly see that I can get
these clauses
by this so-called redundance based
strengthening rule so note that I have
to specify it's very important that you
can't yes Omega so I have to tell you
what it is so suppose I want to drive
these Clauses in order first I want to
drive a or not X or not Y where a is
fresh my witness will set here a to true
okay and now you realize that nothing
happens to f
and on the right hand side the witness
sets the close to true so that it
vanishes
so I don't have to prove anything
so this now I have derived this loss by
the Redundant space strengthening rule
in the next step I add this Clause now
my witness is the opposite it sets eight
to false
that takes care of the new clause it
doesn't take care of this clause
but now the Assumption not C on the
other side actually says that X is false
and that satisfies this close so it
again banishes so I have nothing to
prove and the same thing happens for not
a or Y
so these are like very very simple cases
of redundancy strengthening but this
tells us that this is like a nice Rule
and you can see that if I specify
the witness then I can get like
verifiable derivation
the second and the third you need the
previous ones or put you to them I could
do this in any order I don't I mean the
things that I'm adding before they don't
sort of help me they're more like they
mess my life up a bit I could do this in
any order it's it's
right can I take this redundance rule
this is sort of extended trigger
and now you could say aren't we done now
because sort of extended trigger can do
any reasoning known to man no
and the problem here is that
is that not that's actually one of the
open questions that we'll get to the end
but the problem is we really care about
the fish
so saying that yeah maybe
if you blow up in the simulation and
that's a non-starter because then you're
going from linear time to cubic time and
if you're looking at a million variables
This Is Not Gonna Fly
yeah
the converse obvious effects
no okay
yeah but I think there are some uh yeah
I'm blanking on the reference so there
are some people who have worked on this
I think maybe I don't know if some
um
forgotten who the original person was
there's a pretty simple proofs to
justifying the value of the variable
this is sort of it's believable but you
have to approve it
um foreign
so what are examples of what satsoblers
might do that Dira doesn't know how to
do well if I have these four Clauses
over X1 to X4 then you look at them and
you realize that this is just a
cardinality constraint saying that at
least two of these variables are true
why white noise May helpful well if you
can extract cardinality constraints that
you could solve the pigeon or principle
in linear time whereas for resolution we
know that it's exponential times
there are solvers implementing this
there hasn't been known any efficient
way to support this with Pro program
and this is sort of the first motivation
why it might be nice to go to zero one
integral linear inequalities except that
when you talk to proof to to sad solving
people you should refer to them as
pseudobullion constraints
which is a much cooler name obviously so
from now on let's not say calling planes
let's say suitable in reasoning clearly
everybody wants to use reasoning it
sounds extremely
but it's just cutting planes we have
zero one integral in inequalities
integral coefficients for
formal reasons it's nice to have like
literals as variables in their own right
if I want to and I can say that x and x
bar just cancel the level one variables
are still true or false zero or one
obviously Clauses are just special cases
of pseudo Boolean inequalities
cardinality constraints or we can have
completely General constraints with
arbitrary integer coefficients
and we reason with these constraints
just using standard cutting planes so
just to make sure that we're on the same
page if I have these two constraints
then I can take a positive linear
combination say this constraint plus two
times this constraint and then I just
collect terms and I guess this
then I can I know for all electrons that
they are non-negative so I know that for
instance z bar is non-negative I can
multiply that by two and add to this and
then cancel out and when the dust
settles I guess that get the three W
plus 6X plus 6y greater equals seven and
then the sort of main rule of cutting
clients if you wish is division which
then says that I can divide through by
three and then on the right hand side I
can round up
and now it's clear that if I just write
down my Clauses in sudo Boolean form add
them up and divide then I can get this
so this means that if my
proof vlogging system would be able to
reason with linear inequalities then I
have a very concise efficient way to
certify this application
I still need the redundance rule
and it will look exactly the same the
only reason is difference now is that c
is no longer a clause it's a general
zero one into the linear inequality
and this gives me
basically extended resolution except for
cutting planes
in particular this is an extension of
the d-rat proof logging system that some
people use what is not obvious at all it
wasn't obvious to us before but it just
is an empirical observation is that this
turns out to be a surprisingly powerful
proof system
it is very convenient you can take a lot
of different off-the-shelf solvers and
look at what they do and it turns out
that a lot of what happens in convertory
optimization actually is cutting place
based recently you're counting different
things you're comparing your different
accounts this is you know cutting planes
can do this I mean there's a reason why
we struggle to prove cutting place lower
bumps it's a fairly intelligent proof
system it can do non-privilance
um
one thing that it can do and that we
haven't had proof vlogging for before is
supposed to actually given a suitable in
Formula or a like a zero one integer
linear program one way of solving this
is to introduce extension variables and
say that well X1 plus x two plus six
three plus six four greater equal to is
equivalent to this formula
okay and this is something that is
actually being done you get like a zero
one internally in your program you take
some smart translations to Clauses you
run a set solver and if the set solver
says onset then you believe that your
zero one integral in your program is on
set
the only problem is like is it obvious
that this is actually the same as this
um and it's not then again these are the
kind of solvers where you would actually
see bugs from time to time and what I
don't have time to tell you about but
what we have a paper about this summer
was that using this cutting planes with
this extension rule you get fairly slick
proofs that this uh kind of
representation can be derived from this
okay so that means that you can first
prove the correctness of the translation
to CNF and then you concatenate this
with a sub-solving standard proof of
improve and now you actually have
end-to-end verification of the whole
process
the stats already never reasons with
anything other than Clauses but the fact
that we are reasoning with zero one into
the linear inequalities helps us to
certify the correctness of the whole
process
another thing that sat solver would do
that I mentioned for for instance
cryptographic problems
is parity reasoning so suppose I have
these four clauses
and these four Clauses then I claim that
I should be able to derive xor.w and not
xow
is this well it's easier if you write
down these four Clauses are just saying
that the parity of x and Y and Z is on
these Clauses if you look at them say
that the parity of y z and W is on and
now if you just sum up these two parties
clearly X and W must have even paired
but we know that resolution doesn't
support this because saving formulas are
hard for resolution there are solvers
using this again if your solver uses
parity reasoning you can't take part in
the main track of the sub competition
um this is an example of where we know
that direct proofrogen can do this but
all suggested Solutions so far just
don't scale you pick up something like a
linear or quadratic factor and that's
just too bad
and now what is not so obvious is that
cutting planes with extensional
variables can do this in a very Nifty
Way by I'll write my parity
constraint in the following way the X
Plus y plus Z plus two a equals three
where a is a new Fresh variable
if you look at this you realize that
this is just a stupid way of saying
that's a party as well and in the same
way this constraint says that the party
is on and now when you add them you get
X plus W plus an even number times lots
of things is equal to an even number and
now you realize that this constraint
actually says
that the parity of X and Y W is even
and then if you work a little bit more
it turns out that you can actually
efficiently this is not obvious you have
to do a little bit of work but now you
can extract efficiently these
inequalities is our exactly these
thoughts
and this skins very nice too so again
this is something that we have
implemented and you get an order of
magnitude faster profiling improved
verification that has been the case
and
going beyond that so I
am running a little bit of the time I'll
say this just very quickly so
it turns out that you can also take
cutting planes and you can certify what
state-of-the-art graph solvers for like
for instance for Max click for subgraph
isomorphism for maximum common connected
subgraph
what they do you can write down
efficient cutting planes proof although
cutting planes doesn't know where the
graph is
but still the way these solvers are
reasoning about graphs fit nicely with
cutting plates
although cutting planes doesn't know
what the general integer is you can
actually encode an integer as just this
exponential sum of the bits and then you
can do things like that constraint
programming solvers would do and provide
efficient proofs of course
there's one caveat here
if I'm given a graph as an input and I'm
going to solve subgraph isomorphism then
I somehow have to pre-translate the
graph sub graph for example resistance
problem into a zero one into their
linear program so that cutting planes
can understand the program problem okay
this is something that should be
formally verified we don't have it
formally verified at this point again
this is another point where you should
use interacting theorem interactive
Theory improvers or something it's
completely within reach but it's work
that needs to be done
but this is sort of for many of these
problems again if you think about your
favorite and the complete problem it's
very easy to write it as a zero one
integrity
and it's not hard to prove that indeed
like this is the correct formalization
um
what about symmetries so symmetries show
up again optimization they show up in
hard benchmarks if you think again if
you go to the proof complexity literally
turns out like most of the formulas that
are hard
are actually hard because of symmetry I
guess the like the only example maybe
that we don't have
maybe I have a random kcnfs are not
symmetric I guess but otherwise many
formulas that we have lower bounds for
are symmetric one way or another
again
the style of symmetries that you have
your high broken by d-rat but it's
complicated enough that it actually
hasn't been implemented in principle
there should be solvers that break
pigeonhole style symmetries and emit the
red proofs and take part in the sub
competition there are no such solos
um so what can you do with symmetries
one thing you can do is like break
symmetries to get for instance the
lexicographic with small Solutions uh
you could also if you don't want to
change the set of solutions you can do
something that is called symmetric
learning where anytime you derive a
consequence you say oh any symmetric
version of this consequence should also
be valid
okay
there have been one proof logging system
proposed for symmetric learning which
basically just says take a proof system
and extend it with knowledge of
permutations and symmetries and that
kind of thing there are two reasons for
not liking that
firstly because it turns out that if you
do it in this way then you this is
incompatible with all the pre-processing
techniques that are also used so it's
not very useful
and it's also in some sense it's clear
that whatever kind of reasoning you want
to do you could also add an always add
an ad hoc rule that does say parity
reasoning or cardinality reasoning or
symmetry breaking but the problem is
when you take all of these rules
together your proof system is getting
very complicated and soundness becomes
hard to understand and to verify so
somehow the aesthetic is that we really
want to keep the proof system as simple
as possible we don't want it to know
about symmetries or permutations or
anything you know if we can get away
with just knowing what they're wanting
to really you know linear inequalities
are then we would be very happy
so we'll try to do that but at the price
of adding one more extension rule which
I think uh Neil will talk more about
after the break because this is an
interesting rule in understanding how
powerful this rule is and whether it's
really important in order to introduce
this rule we'll think about optimization
problems so in this talk I consciously
Focus just on on decision problems
because it's easier and it's a SAT
Workshop our proof logging system also
works in a much more General
optimization setting but even if we
don't have an optimization setting I can
invent Nothing Stops me from inventing
an objective okay so my objective will
be some Interlinear combination for
integers W literals Li
and I think that my problem as say
minimizing this subject to my formula
what is a proof of optimality well a
proof of optimality would be first to
check that you have a satisfying
assignment and then you have a proof of
contradiction from your original formula
handed together with the requirement
that you should find a better solution
strict inequality is just syntactic
sugar since we're doing discrete
problems there is no strict inequality
it just means less equal minus one plus
whatever this is actually a little bit
important because this is this is
something you can run into problem with
if you start doing proof vlogging for
more like the linear programming and
extensive linear programming solvers
and now
now once we have this more General
optimization setting
nothing stopped
stop from
solving a decision problems
while at the same time minimizing say
two to the I times exam
what does that mean well I'm sort of
searching for the lexicographically
smaller satisfying assignment
so
how does the proof system change so
standard cutting claims is still okay
once I've found a solution I will allow
constraints that allow me to cut
branches that cannot have better
Solutions
I also need to be aware of my objective
when I use the redundance rule it's not
okay just that the witness flips to a
satisfying assignment I also want to
make sure that it's not okay if I
flipped an assignment that gives me a
worse objective so this is this new
thing that says that whenever I flip
with respect to Omega it doesn't
increase my objective
okay
so now
with this adding objective our rule
becomes this
and now here comes the key observation
if my witness is good enough I could
actually make a much more aggressive
group
so note that here from F and Lot C I
have to prove all of F and C under the
Restriction Omega plus that the
objective doesn't increase
but now if I can prove that actually the
flipping strictly decreases the
objective
then I don't need then I only need to
reprove F I don't need to prove the
constraint that I want to ask
okay so note here that the difference
between these rules I I have removed the
proof Target now there's no C here
but on the other hand I'm proving strict
and equality
okay so why is this okay
well very quickly
it is okay for the following reason
that suppose again what are we worried
about we're worrying about Alpha
satisfying F but violating D well in
that case I know that Alpha composed
with Omega satisfies f and has strictly
smaller objective value
and now if this new Alpha composed with
Omega satisfies D then I'm happy
otherwise I can run this rule again and
I get Alpha composed with no mirror
composed with Omega which gives me a
strictly smaller objective
now either I satisfy d
or I run this again and I get a chain of
new assignments that have smaller
smaller objective
and this has to terminate
so this dominance rule is kind of
some kind of limited induction rule that
says you know that if I run this rule
enough many times then I would finally
find a satisfying assignment
so let me just do this in one shot
and in fact you can do it even slightly
stronger
it turns out that if you have derived
new constraints before and I want to add
an MF constraint I don't need to reprove
these constraints I only need to recruit
my original performance
and it's basically the same proof as
before
and this turns out to be so this is like
the cutting planes with this redundance
rule I told you about before
and this new dominance rule turns out to
be able to do pretty much all techniques
that have ever been used in modern sad
solving except for symmetric learning
and it turns out that it can also do
symmetry breaking in more General
paradigms such as constraint programming
but time is flying fast so I don't have
time to say too much about that so I
want to now to say okay like what is
actually the formal proof system if you
want to do proof complexity about this
I won't give you the
full formal version I'll give you a
version for like Precision problems and
slightly simplify
so because of these
you like need to know for these kinds of
rules you need to know what constraints
you are currently having in your
database so it's a configuration based
book system a proof is a sequence of
configurations every configuration
contains a set of core constraints which
you could think of as the input formula
and then another set of constraints that
you have derived and you sort of know at
all times that if you really need to you
can recover the derived constraints from
the core constraint so you don't need to
worry too much about those
and then if you're doing symmetry
braking or if you're doing optimization
you have some kind of objective app some
linear objective
you can always you can always apply
standard cutting planes rules and
anything you derive you put it in the
derived
um and let's maybe ignore the rules for
for how to deal with optimization
problems and just focus on subtle side
now here are the formal descriptions of
our strengthening Roots so the Redundant
space strengthening rule it says if I
have the course at C and the derived set
d
and I want to add a new constraint C
then I need to show that c from C Union
D Union the new navigation of the new
constraint I can derive all of them
under this witness substitution Omega
and I'm not making my objective words
whereas the dominance rule
has a stronger requirement on the
objective it says that the objective
should decrease strictly but note that I
got rid of a lot of proof targets here I
got rid of all of the and also I got rid
of the new
I only need to reprove essentially my
original formula and note that for
instance now if you're doing symmetry
breaking I'm saying this very quickly
but basically
if you're doing symmetry breaking then
this witness would typically be a
symmetry so that syntactically this is
the same as this so you don't even have
to write down the group you just have
the verifier should check that
everything is exactly the same
in order to make this into a proof
system it's important that the witness
should be explicitly written down
and also this is a derivation symbol so
there will be like a sub derivation for
for each of these constraints or if the
derivation is obvious enough then
sometimes you can just sort of ask the
proof tracker to fill in the details
this will be important in practice it's
not important for like the theoretical
analysis of the proof
one thing that happens with this type of
proof system is the suddenly deletion
becomes very important you have no
restrictions on deletions from the
derived set but you cannot derive from
the corset
in general like you can only erase
something from the core set if you can
derive if you can rederive it from the
core minus the thing that you erase
either by cutting plants or by the
Redundant space rectangles and the
reason is that actually if you don't
have this then it turns out that with
the proof system you can take a
satisfiable formula and prove that it
sounds satisfiable this is slightly
subtle but uh so you have to be a little
bit careful in practice if you want to
do
proof vlogging for like real world
combinatorial solvers then there are
also some hacky special cases that you
can add and that you would add but again
like the the abstract version would be
this
and and now you realize that if you want
to delete then
it might be useful to shift things that
you have derived into the core set so
there is a way of you there's a rule for
just saying okay I want to shift some
constraints from the drive set to the
core set in order to be able to do
deletion for instance or in order to
change the order because I can when
you're doing symmetry breaking it's
sometimes useful to break with respect
to different symmetries they might
sometimes be encoded by different orders
and if you think about it carefully then
you realize that changing the order
should be okay if you make sure that the
derived set is empty when you change the
order
I'm doing this it's like extremely fast
but there's a third details in the in
the paper
okay
with this proof system you so in ongoing
work we're now showing that you can lift
this from sat solink to Max stat solving
um so sub-based optimization
uh we already are starting to do it for
General constraint programming
uh there's a completely different proof
system being explored in Berlin that is
trying to do mixed into the linear
program which is somewhat similar in
spirit
satisfiability modular theories would be
nice to do but then you probably need
richer Logics because you have these
logical theories that would be a like a
third application of maybe interacting
theorem approvers or more stronger
theories
on the proof complexity side three
questions
symmetric learning I mentioned that we
don't have proof login for that yet
there is sort of there is a way of doing
it but it is not super efficient it
would be really nice to understand
whether you can do substitution proofs
efficiently in this proof system I know
how to do it but not as efficiently as I
would like
we don't know if this fancy dominance
rule is necessary to do symmetry
breaking we know it's sufficient I still
think it's a very uh reasonable question
to ask whether extended fragrah could do
fully General symmetry baking
efficiently we just don't know
um I think it would be interesting also
to understand this dominance rule does
it add anything
are we still within extended Trigger or
are we actually somehow outside of
extended trigger I think this is an
interesting performance from the
question that maybe Neil will will
comment on after the break
and there are many many more interesting
questions and applications you know
we're aiming to take over the whole
world of community organization and
change it to get certifiable proofs of
of correctness you're welcome to join
the revolution if you want we're hiring
um
and with this uh so yeah so although
this is a proof complexity Workshop I
started talking about combinatorial
solving and optimization
the connection to proof complexity is
that ensuring correctness is like the
elephant in the room here certifying
solver seems to be the answer that's
really applied proof complexity we can
use all the tools that we like but to
prove upper bounds not lower bonds
um just empirically
I don't know why but it just seems that
cutting things is a wonderful proof
system it just works it's beautiful
um and I think it's interesting when you
extend cutting planes with this
dominance based and redundance-based
strengthening what kind of proof systems
do you get how does it relate to other
proof systems that we know and love
um I think these are theoretical
questions that are worthy of further
stuff
cool thanks
yeah if you want to change your
dominance order halfway through the
proof you have to be really careful but
could you just not just not start
throwing away the previous DS or
something like that like to go camp if
you indicated but it still works I mean
what you would do is basically you you
do your dominance breaking with respect
to some order and then the things that
you want to keep you can keep them but
now you have to transfer them to the
core which means that they will then be
among the proof targets when you're
doing symmetry breaking with the New
Order and it's not so hard to see that
like if you don't have this then you can
break symmetry so that everything goes
into like the largest painting goes into
the smallest hole another great symmetry
so that the smallest kitchen goes into
the smallest folder and then I
immediately have a contradiction even if
there are enough holes right so makes
sense and the other question was is
there for dran style systems or we have
this unit of propagation makes this sort
of this this one implies is an easy to
check things there are an analog and
cutting planes I'm an easy to check
Community propagation transfers exactly
to uh to to pseudobular Concepts to zero
one into the lane inequalities
um there's like the natural definition
and indeed that would I'm sort of
sweeping that under the rug a lot of our
proofs would be based on Captain planes
unit propagation reverse unit
propagation that will be the Workhorse I
mean you use the double term style in
your definition if there is that what
you
no
and the final formal definition
of a single Turn Style right so there
will be proofs but I will have sort of
my proof system will allow me if
something follows by reverse unit
propagation then I can just claim it so
you can basically you add reversing the
propagation as a rule
and that's okay because it's a
polynomial
okay
I was wondering if there is some
fragment of this Newport systems maybe
without using the extension variables
for which you can still prove some lower
bound
even though maybe it's stronger that's
an excellent question yeah that's a yeah
yeah that's a great question which I
should have added and I didn't uh yeah
so you can
that's and I think we're sort of going
to have a talk on a somewhat similar uh
note this this afternoon you can take
these wonderful strong proof systems and
you can say because this this dominance
rule for instance or the point is that
what you can do with these rules is that
c could contain new virus right but I
can take both of these rules and I can
say no you're not you're allowed to use
these rules but you can't use new
variables
and the question is does this make sense
the answer is yes for instance
resolution with the Redundant space
strengthening can solve Satan
efficiently it can solve paternal
principle formula sufficiently
and then it's a very natural question
you know if I forbid new variables but
you still have these rules can I prove
lower bumps that's a great question
and it might be within Rich understand
that you know in the resolution World
there are some results like this like PR
yes I'm not on top of it I think Sam is
the person to talk to or maybe
I think we'll hear about kind of this
this afternoon yes
yeah but I think even for even for
resolution I mean even doing this for
resolution info generality would still
be interesting because the sort of the
the I think
even the resolution
if I remember correctly have further
restrictions
but it's a great question it's like you
know it might be within reach it's
clearly very hard but my video
okay
stop now
foreign